in the last video we were able to
construct here in red this long run
average total cost curve based on
connecting the minimum points or the
bottoms of the u's of our various short
run average total cost curves each of
those short short run average total cost
curves were based on a certain amount of
fixed costs in the short run but in the
long run you can change your fixed costs
and here are fixed costs for the number
of trucks and so we can vary it to
optimize for a certain amount of
quantity now when we did that you could
see a little trend here especially as we
go up to the way i drew it it wouldn't
necessarily be up to 200 of whatever
you're producing but the way i drew it
you see that this part right over here
it looks like our long run average total
cost curve is declining down so we one
way to think about it is we are getting
more and more efficient at producing our
tacos in the long run
as we produce more of them until we get
to 200 tacos and so
at this part of our curve we are
experiencing economies
economies of scale
and we've talked about where economies
of scale can come from it can come from
specialization
of
labor or even machine specialization
as you get more and more scaled you can
have different parts of your process
specializing in baking the taco shells
or grating the cheese or cooking the
meat whatever it is so there's a
specialization you could get better at
sourcing
so as you get more scale you might be
able to order more of your supplies at a
time so you get better deals you might
be able to even who knows at some point
start a farm yourself and then cut out
the middlemen and so forth and so on
now as we get past that point we see
that our long run average total cost
curve at least in this example started
to trend up
and so this part of the curve you could
say that we are experiencing
diseconomies of scale this economies
of scale
so what would cause diseconomies of
scale well these would most typically
happen because what are known as
coordination issues as an organization
grows you have more people more
resources that you have to coordinate
and so that complexity can sometimes
make an organization more inefficient
there's other diseconomies of scale at
some very large scale you might be
depleting all of the low hanging fruit
of your inputs and so you have to pay
more for some of your inputs maybe
you've already depleted the people who
are willing to work for less so you have
to raise wages or you've depleted a lot
of the resources you need so you have to
find new more expensive resources
now in this curve it's not as obvious
but you can also have a notion of
constant returns to scale so if we had a
long run average total cost curve that
looked something like this let me draw
it over here
then in this section right over here
as the average total cost the long run
average total cost is going down
that would be economies of scale
this section over here as the long run
average total cost is going up that
would be our diseconomies of scale but
this section over here where it is
constant you might guess what that is
called that is refer that is called
constant economies of scale or constant
returns to scale sometimes known as
efficient scale